ah let's try the English symmetrical
English or not okay well let's do this
d4 and if night here I might want to
consider f3 I also might not want to
consider that right now ah ok well
what's the scope here Bishop d 2 2 C 3
i'm going to try that let's see can i
get rid of that Bishop right away and
let me try this I do not know if this is
correct but I'm gonna run with it I
cannot take the pond just yet so let's
play here and now maybe knight to e 2 or
actually let's go f3 there I don't have
to worry about a pin right now and I
want to cover this square that's so sure
I want to allow the night to play here
so easily and now guess what the dark
square Bishop scum off the board and
well yeah let me make sure the dark star
[ __ ] does come off the board and get
developed because that's what you're
supposed to do in the beginning and
you're also supposed to Castle cuz
that's development and I'm considering
this and I'm considering just taking and
planning f4 I think I like that I'm okay
with giving up my dark might my dark
'scrimish if I'm okay with giving up my
lightscribe ashab i'm looking to get an
e5 right now and i have a space
advantage and a safer king if i play
here it is allowing for the bishop to
play to f5 but i don't know well maybe i
could consider f5 and then e five ideas
just so that the bishop won't be able to
make use of the f five square and maybe
i can get at the King a little bit
easier if this Jeep on is converted to
an F pawn even though it's doubled okay
so let me throw a question that Bishop
he needs to do something else and now
pawn push here
f5 g4 eventually when I go for it Bishop
f5 Queen f3 and with G for coming i'm
just basically trying to launch all of
my pawns at black i guess there is this
h5 idea and with that black is saying
you know what if you're going to play g4
you're going to do that at the cost of
opening up the H file now I could take
here play g4 I like I think first just
taking being assured that I have play
against this F pond at some point there
is the possibility for a past d pun as
well I could do this and the bishop is
close to just running out of squares I
like this as a start however might there
be something better such as Queen g3
threatening rook takes bishop or d6
hitting the Queen and vacating the d5
square for my night which would be
coming with tempo I think there's
something to this move but let me first
see what that bishop is up to let's see
about that bishop is the Queen really
going to take here now now she's not so
where does he go is he too good for his
home bishop CA or Bishop to d7 ah i
think this followed by queen f6 stuff is
going to be pretty good let's seeing
pawn push night here Queen here check
followed by night here this seems good
let's do it it seems really good Queen
might have to run home this is I think I
think my opponent is dead meat now Queen
here followed by night d 52 e 7 is tkl
and the all let me just let me make sure
of it hang on if i play here i'm pretty
sure that King has to play to h6 and if
he does play to h6 I think that's
running into am a queen f6 here check
king h5
there's got to be mate right around the
corner right Queen check King takes pawn
Queen check is it necessary to even
calculate all that here and then my
night could probably give black a
beating at some point let's do this
first let's see if black is even going
to run here let them do the calculation
ok now it's a lot cleaner because I'm
playing here on the Queen and knight to
e7 that's TKO the King has no squares ok
I think the best choice was to actually
just run like crazy in this direction
hope that there wasn't some mating net
but there probably would be I was it was
tough right there this the space
advantage that I ended up getting let's
go back here let's see about this back
it up and let me flip the board I don't
know about what what do I not know about
the d6 move I think you should maybe go
with this I don't know if there was some
fear of maybe me playing d6 to
compromise the central structure but I
think you could run with this right now
and at least allow for maybe if Knight
c3 there is this Bishop takes Knight
move that you could be running with you
give up a very important piece but you I
there's some there's pros and cons to it
and you know that's that's a way that's
a way to go there don't don't feel
compelled to do this d6 move by playing
d6 you are allowing for me to get this
maneuver in and I don't know that you
should allow me to get that maneuver in
so easily if you do this right now of
course I can't play here so I'm dropping
my pond so maybe that's a slight tweak
of the earlier moves right there instead
of d6 Bishop g7 right aways may be best
if the dark square Bishop scum off this
is a problem for your king and
sure enough that's what ends up
happening problems on the dark squares
but I mean I couldn't defend I could not
have anticipated it happening like that
so I mean what do you what do you do I
don't know maybe that's maybe that's the
beginning of bad things happening to be
honest because development is real
smooth here I know we're trading pieces
a little bit and maybe that was
something black was looking into seeing
how I have a space advantage in trading
pieces is going to be a good thing but
notice the development that I now have
you're getting the night for Bishop type
of situation but these ponds are just so
menacing pressing forward with 'if i I'm
fully developed your king is exposed
right here on this diagonal and this f
file can open up there's possibilities
for Brooke up and overs lateral movement
already in this Queens queenside
expansion this typical idea with this
current pawn structure this benoni
structure there's b5 advances a long way
off from accomplishing good things for
black it's just it's not coming in time
this b5 idea i don't know how disruptive
it would even turn out to be but the
action is going to happen then center
really really soon already I'm ready to
play e5 so I think already consider
right now just getting your Bishop don't
allow for this Bishop d2 to c3 idea i
think this turns out to be pretty good
you stop the dark square Bishop exchange
but eventually it's welcomed when your
night when the night plays to g4 don't
know that you could allow for that
that's my that's my main suggestion and
that's that's drawn to it again because
that is where an imbalance occurs well
not now not an imbalance that's where
the trade of your most valuable minor
piece occurs he's the most valuable guy
if you're going to go with the kingside
tree and cut out so consider an
immediate Bishop to g7 instead of d 6
which is going to stop
22 c3 idea for my queen Bishop